bonsoir à tout ce nous sommes lundi 5
septembre je suis ravi de vous retrouver
pour cette édition de rentrée de 7,8 le
journal on commence tout de suite avec
les petits trains
l'université du medef c'était la semaine
dernière à jouy en josas un événement
très politisée et marqué par la campagne
pour les primaires de la droite et du
centre politique toujours dans un
contexte agité à droite en sait-on de
primaires nous reviendrons sur la
candidature d'alain juppé le maire de
bordeaux s'est rendu dans les yvelines à
chatou pour sa campagne et enfin nous
parlerons de la rentrée scolaire au
programme de réforme des collèges et
mesures de sécurité et les patrons eux
aussi ont fait leur rentrée quelles sont
leurs problématiques ce qui les
préoccupe ils en ont parlé lors de
l'université d'été du medef elle a eu
lieu la semaine dernière à jouy en josas
deux jours très marquée par la présence
des politiques mais également la
démission des manuels macron alors qu'en
ont pensé les patrons à yves binois
éléments de réponse sur des images
signées camille lambert
dernière échéance avant la primaire de
la droite du 9 septembre les politiques
ont défilé à jouy en josas à
l'université d'été du medef pour
rencontrer et conquérir les
entrepreneurs présents les intervenants
que ça soit françois fillon hier nicolas
sarkozy ce matin où bruno le maire et
puis cet après midi à la jupe est
effectivement souhaite faire bouger les
choses mais ils ont déjà été également
pouvoir en tous les cas pour faire
pincer des choses ont bougé ne le bouge
pas suffisamment les plénières sont très
orientés politique mais il reste encore
des interventions
très ciblées notamment sur le tourisme
dans l'espace innovation qui sont assez
intéressants avec des belles tables
rondes donc effectivement ça couvre sur
tout l'espace médiatique sur le reste
quand même du fond et des conférences
assez intéressante sur votre sujet deux
jours pour parler des problématiques et
économique la 18e édition a élu la
semaine dernière au campus dacheux c'est
un moment pour faire le bilan de l'année
écoulée et ses futurs prospectives c'est
au sénat où on lance des idées on a les
thèmes de réflexion et des ateliers où
on travaille c'est également un moment
de rencontre entre différents
partenaires des fortes forme de
mouvement d et des autres c'est parce
qu'on a beaucoup d'invités des
politiques
conférences débats et tables rondes se
sont succédé autour des thèmes de la
conquête l'audace ou encore l'
enthousiasme avec un slogan cette année
y croire et agir c'est un appel et
j'espère que vale politique les
dirigeants d'entreprises qui sont là
l'ont entendu et c'est important pour
les jeunes pour les nouvelles
générations dans tant de ça et de change
et du climat actuel qu'on a une édition
très politisé marquée par la démission
des manuels macron mais aussi son
absence comme celle de représentants du
gouvernement
et la primaire de la droite et du centre
s'annonçait déjà très mouvementée le
parquet de paris a requis ce lundi 5
septembre le renvoi en correctionnelle
de nicolas sarkozy concernant la sphère
du financement illégal de la campagne
électorale les juges d'instruction ont
donc a maintenant un mois pour suivre ou
rejeter cette réquisition ce
rebondissement judiciaire pourrait
bousculer la primaire peut être au
profit du maire de bordeaux pour son
premier meeting de septembre alain juppé
s'est rendu à chatou c'était le samedi
27 août un reportage a signé nicolas
landry sur des images ni est une
première pour nous c'est le vrai
lancement aujourd'hui cela c'est vrai
démarrage de ces primaires pour sa
rentrée politique alain juppé et son
équipe ont choisi les yvelines entouré
de jean pierre raffarin et de gérard
larcher le candidat à la primaire de la
droite et du centre a tenu un meeting à
chatou le 27 août dernier un déplacement
placé sous le signe du dialogue avec les
français et les représentants des
collectivités locales
je m'appuie beaucoup sur les élus locaux
sur les mers embardée guljé que j'ai
beaucoup rencontrés tout au long de ces
deux années je suis moi-même mer donc on
se parle le collègue collègues comme je
le dis souvent ils sont un peu
l'ossature de la république ils sont
toujours en première ligne vis-à-vis de
leurs concitoyens à leur grande force
c'est précisément cette proximité que
vous évoquez et alain juppé compte de
nombreux soutiens dans le département
avec dans leurs rangs des élus heavy moi
c'est une bonne chose aussi parce qu'une
grande manifestation républicaine pour
la ville de chatou on en parle on
parlait jusqu'à présent des
impressionnistes pour son pôle culturel
maintenant on va en parler pour le jour
1 de l'accession au pouvoir d'alain
juppé j'espère en avril 2017 et le pacte
gagnant gagnant qui propose avec les
élus de terrain qui sont finalement les
personnes les plus proches de nos
administrés me va bien pour l'équipe
d'alain juppé les meetings se poursuivre
les candidatures pour la primaire
doivent être déposées avant le 9 pour le
début de la campagne officielle prévue
le 21 septembre
et on ouvre à présent une page rentrée
scolaire le ton et la plage ont laissé
place aux stylos et cahiers les élèves
de saint quentin en yvelines ont repris
le chemin de l'école c'était jeudi
dernier nous montrer sous le soleil mais
aussi avec le sourire comme à l'école
primaire francis poulenc à guyancourt où
s'est rendu nicolas qui rit le vide se
regarder
à regarder leurs visages on les croirait
presque encore en vacances l'heure de la
rentrée a pourtant sonné pour les 120
élèves de l'école primaire francis
poulenc de guyancourt retrouvailles avec
les camarades histoire des vacances et
pour les plus sérieux déjà le travail
lorenzo dix ans un seul objectif en tête
la sixième bah on commence à parler de
nos vacances mais retrait quand on doit
se mettre au travail on s'y met c'est ma
dernière année et au et après je vais
commencer bien travaillé pour après
passer en sixième les enseignants font
connaissance avec leur classe et les
nouveautés de la rentrée madame sa voix
est professeur des écoles en cu à elle
partage cette année ses heures de cours
avec une collègue chaque classe est
différente et cette année je n'ai pas eu
c1 depuis un certain temps donc
effectivement c'est pour moi c'est aussi
un renouveau tout à fait de maîtresses
et plus
on est plus on est plus exigeante fait
en verre
et en deux maîtresses et
je suis vois pas de pour être honnête je
vois pas d'inconvénient la rentrée une
journée particulière également pour la
directrice de l'école comptait gérer et
dispatcher des missions qui peuvent
s'avérer compliqué lorsqu'on découvre un
nouvel établissement et a été déjà
directrice deux ans d'un gymnase d'une
école que je connaissais ça a été là
c'est une ville que je ne connais pas
une école que je ne connais pas donc ça
ajoute du stress mais j'étais tellement
bien accueilli que non ça s'est bien
passé lorsqu'on arrive dans une école il
faut pas tout bouleverser ça vous faire
cela l'équipe enseignante sa bouleversé
les et enfants et je pense que s'il ya
déjà des choses qui a été mis en place
et qui fonctionne il faut toujours les
faire perdurer élèves enseignants et
direction devront désormais attendre le
19 octobre prochain pour souffler à
nouveau ce sera alors le début des
vacances de la toussaint
et on passe à présent à la rentrée à des
plus grands prés de 80 mille collégiens
et 5000 enseignants ont fait leur
rentrée dans les collèges les yvelinois
la nouveauté cette année c'est la
réforme du collège avait contesté par
une partie des syndicats elle comprend
entre autres l'interdisciplinarité
l'aide personnalisée et le développement
du numérique le recteur de l'académie de
versailles s'est rendu au collège de la
joie à elancourt pour défendre ces
nouveautés nicolas landry était sur
place
pour les élèves et les enseignants le
changement c'est pour maintenant avec la
réforme du collège sur fond de
contestation syndicale le recteur de
l'académie de versailles a tenu à
défendre ces transformations notamment
d'ordre pédagogique
l'aide personnalisée qui fait que les
professeurs ont travaillé avec les
élèves par groupe soit parce que
certains ont de difficultés en faisant
travailler ceux qui ont plus
plus réussis et à côté d'autres élèves
une pédagogie aussi par projet à travers
les enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire la réforme du collège
apporterait de la progressivité dans
l'évaluation les classes de 5e 4e et 3e
seront penser globalement avec une
adaptation du programme par rapport à
l'évolution des compétences des élèves
chaque année c'est un processus pendant
trois ans pendant lequel les professeurs
doivent s'étaler les acquisitions pas
les répéter chaque année les pensées par
rapport à un objectif c'est ça le grand
changement ces changements facilitera
l'intégration du numérique dans les
collèges une priorité dans l'académie de
versailles avec son plan numérique pour
l'éducation le recteur a donné un kit
composé d'une tablette d'un
rétroprojecteur et d'une caméra à
l'ambassadeur numérique du collège de
l'avion ça me permet de beaucoup mieux
ciblés de beaucoup mieux différencier
les apprentissages et de personnaliser
mon apprentissage par rapport à chaque
élève tous les élèves de 6e du collège
de l'avion ont reçu une tablette à la
rentrée 24000 ont été prévus pour cette
rentrée dans toute l'académie de
versailles avec un espoir à la clé une
augmentation de la réussite des élèves
et c'est aussi un sujet qui concerne la
rentrée scolaire sus aux attaques des
terroristes est la menace terroriste le
gouvernement a instauré de nouvelles
mesures pour les établissements
scolaires policiers patrouillent aux
supplémentaires système d'alertés sms
pour le chef d'établissement et
exercices de sécurité sont au programme
plusieurs dispositifs détaillé par le
recteur de l'académie de versailles
daniel filâtre écoutez le
notre travail notre devoir c'est
anticiper anticipé ensuite sécurisé nos
établissements et puis prévenir en cas
de en cas de drame et nous travaillons
avec des référents sécurité nous avons
développé des cellules risques et nous
mettons en oeuvre des diagnostics
sécurité des exercices dans chacune de
nos écoles et nos établissements d'ici
les vacances de tout ça notre sujet on
prend à présent la direction de la
verrière le nouveau à gina s'appelle
officielle officiellement pardon gymnase
de la fraternité m'ont choisie par les
verriers roi lors d'un vote plus de 460
personnes se sont exprimées la ville l'a
inauguré officiellement ce samedi 3
septembre la rénovation a duré un peu
plus d'un an pour un montant d'un
million 3 financés par l'anru des
modifications à deux salles ont été
apportées écouter ces précisions
recueillies par mélanie potier
et vraiment c'est un peu vieillot déjà
correspondait plus trop aux attentes des
gens qui luttent eu de nouvelles
dans la profité pour
nouvelle salle
c'est que la musculation
un endroit que ça dit quoi tout ce qu'on
aime
le
transport à présent le réseau et ski bus
est passé en horaires d'hiver depuis le
1er septembre n'est pas d'aller vérifier
vos trajets les nouveaux horaires sont
disponibles à lagence de la mobilité la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines et sur
le site internet de ski bus et enfin
cette dernière information avant de
refermer ce journal nicolas sarkozy
candidat à la primaire de la droite et
du centre sera demain dont les ivy pour
s'exprimer notamment sur le thème de
l'éducation c'est à présent la fin de
cette édition je vous remercie de nous
avoir suivis tout de suite vous
retrouvez le 7-8 les invités présenté
par wilfrid est riche il suivit d'une
statue sport nouvelle formule je vous
retrouve demain pour le journal et vous
souhaite une excellente soirée